hi my name is George Woodrow and my talk
at the Wolfram conference is going to be
about Eliza's legacy chatbots
today's martin gardner's birthday those
of us who over a certain age will
remember him from his articles and
scientific american i saw a quote today
that said he made children into
mathematicians and mathematicians and
the children so I don't think Martin
Gardner had an article on Eliza but he
had a article on almost everything else
had happened in the 50s and 60s and 70s
so here we go just a little background
Eliza is an early artificial
intelligence program developed in 1960s
by Joseph bison bomb thing wisin bomb I
never heard his name at MIT and it
emulated originally and psychotherapist
I came across a program in 1970s when a
version basic was published by creative
cute computing I was a researcher at the
University of Pennsylvania at that time
and when I wrote the code and showed it
to other well to the graduate students I
was amazed as some of them actually
thought there was a person in find
graduate students was so gullible
Eliza's arguably the first chatbot today
they're all over the place I mean I
found a website that uses a chat bot to
help people be parking tickets in new
york city and i think a couple of the
city seat but New York's I live right
near New York so undoubtedly some of the
chat windows that I've been at talking
to support their I was actually talking
to computer at least some of the time so
I became interested in using a chat bout
when I was talking to my local college
my alma mater actually math department
about using mathematic in the classroom
and I was dissatisfied by the fact that
they only wanted me to use things that
had like true false questions and multi
well guess questions as a means of
assessment I said you know this is the
place is charging forty thousand dollars
a year in tuition they're more expensive
than Princeton they should be a little
more creative than that my feeling is
that the best use of the computers to
help students achieve mastery and that
involves some sort of interaction and
that's when I remembered the Eliza
program I poked around I found the
source sort of the basic source code
somebody had put up a command line
version in mathematic in 1992 and the
program really doesn't need to be
complete if eighty percent of material
can be covered by using computer than
the time the student spends with the
teacher will be much more useful and we
can also count on the student or other
user to be helpful I mean if you're on a
website trying to get something out of
customer service you're not going to be
off talking nonsense to them so I hope
to show you complete instructional
application at the conference
unfortunately our indie phase took way
longer than I thought
okay ya think I'm out of here no I'm not
there we go the lives that was
originally written as a command line
program for what was then an innovative
time sharing computer system obviously
an interactive program would not work if
using punch cards and you had a 24 hour
turnaround time coincidentally I learned
on a time-sharing system if I had used
punch cards I probably wouldn't have
learned to program at all it was easy
enough to create the user interface for
the conversation as you can see here
this is just a mock-up I emulated the
mac OS message application pretty much
all of the same and stephen in fact
showed a implementation for the web
interface in Mathematica looked pretty
much the same i just didn't put in the
little pointy things coming out of the
sides of the conversation real
difficulty is inputting text and we
needed a way to have the input field
that essentially worked like the command
line interface if we just sit there way
for you to type something and then do
some processing once you hit the return
or Enter key and there are three
different options that I tried I'm only
going to show you the one that worked so
i was totally stumped this is a major
part of the R&D that took me so long i
just couldn't get the thing to work i
knew about if end handler Kyle Martin in
the technology group did some speed
linking and he found something that
worked and here's the basic code I think
you know this is already implemented so
you just type in your message you notice
that the ah brackets not executing and
then it just comes back and it just so
that's it now I was the key thing this
is the key and you could probably use
this code in a lot of other situations
besides making a chatbot so here's a
working chat bot the this code is
available as a package on the passable
thing and it's also in a non package
format it's in this notebook so you can
just type something in and oops it's
pretty dumb because my simple processor
is really really dumb now we get to the
working example and because i'm using
the ethernet for the Wi-Fi for the
internets this should be work
and
[Music]
kind of works uh there are a couple
things that I notice about this first is
it was a really amazing in the 60s and
70s isn't now the next thing is that
everyone expects spell checking and it
did not implement that but if you did
something like typed in it knows that
it's not a perfect implementation but
because it doesn't recognize Klingon
anything that's not you can tape
garbling garbage in and it still thinks
it's ah i tried Clint I tried Klingon
really and it still thought it was
thought it was English so the code for
this is that the is at the end i use the
original paper by wisin balm i'm going
to call him that because i'm not sure it
didn't have any code with it and
wouldn't have done any good anyway
because it was an obsolete language on a
computer that doesn't exist anymore but
the basic ideas are there the PDF of
that document is also unpassable so I
looked at all these things here that I
included in some form or another or plan
to text structure which steven alluded
to is really powerful it's not ready for
primetime makes lots of mistakes we'll
talk about that later language identify
works pretty well but it's confused by
short input.text words is what I'm using
here which is why it needs an internet
connection spring spring split does
basically the same thing but not as well
text sentences is something that I want
to do because now it just is everything
they're assuming is just one sentence if
you get for both and associations I
looked at and I said well I'm running
out of time I don't want to have to
learn association so I use something
else instead
I'll try to pump the side screen up on
this one this is the structure basically
what the program does is you get the
input it does some processing turns
everything the lower case turns
everything into a string of words it
looks for key words in the first column
here are equivalent keywords this is a
weight factor so it will look at that
first with a higher weight factor some
pattern matching here and then some
responses so in this case if I had
brother it would look 40 or more words
followed by my with 0 words 0 more words
and then brother the little marker there
is for whatever the keyboard you found
was exactly one word and me and then it
formulates one of these two things
picking out a number four one two three
four so this would say does your brother
really and whatever word was there you
know like me and there are all kinds of
things like that and this is essentially
the structure that the original paper
had the basic program was much simpler
than that it just found the keyboard and
then processed whatever was after the
keyword and it kind of worked that I
didn't really like it ah the problem
with this is that this list of lists of
lists is breaks easily it's hard to
maintain so the next stage will be to
turn this into an association or even
one of these custom entities something
to look into
[Music]
kind of there was a special case there
were we'd look at previous things when
it got stuck but I the basic one didn't
have that and I was you know the way
that they had implemented would have
taken longer to do in mathematica than I
wanted to but yeah the the next stage
here because I you know the Eliza thing
is is cute and all that but it doesn't
really meet any educational need it was
an exercise and seeing what what do we
need so we need to have some kind of
script to follow something to parse the
script in a real application you need to
know about the real world we need a
separate model to work on i mean the the
interface we have here is the view and
this part that i wrote here is kind of
the controller in the script is part of
the model but if i wanted to say write a
program that would help a student with
species counterpoint if we need to know
the rules of species counterpoint we'd
need to know the state of the the
exercises you're going through and
various other things so rather than
implement essentially a one-off i punted
okay
ok
I only drop out of this because it's not
not letting me finish it goes to the
next well let's go to the end to know
see if we can get there okay I put all
the source code at the end and their
comments in there let's go back to the
previous slide ok the next thing to do
is obviously to make something a little
bit less primitive in the script and
there are other things you know
generalize the script for other kinds of
interaction if you had a simple 20
questions type of thing which would be
the chat bot for a you know how to beat
a parking fine then you need a different
kind of script so I wanted to generalize
that so that one style of script would
work pretty much for anything if you
want speaking and lynch and just
listening would be nice ok I'm going to
put all this stuff up on the Wolfram
community and there's my email address
because I just saw something really
shiny to work on next and I'm going to
be doing that and obviously a cloud
deployment would be really nice and if
you did that then you could probably do
some kind of data analysis of the
responses from the website and make
things better the text structure is
something that's Stephen Wolfram said
last night about his work on you know
natural language processing he said well
if you feed poetry into it you're going
to get garbage you know it's not yet
going to lose the meaning of the thing
and from everything that I've been
looking at working on this the line
between what the use of coal steno
language when I was in college had
probably call it something else now you
know instruction manuals that kind of
speech what they
can stein i think it was in
philosophical investigations was looking
at when he was having peoples you know
to hand me a brick hand me this you know
I you quickly get into metaphor right
after that so we're going to need
something that's going to handle
metaphoric communication and my feeling
is that metaphors all over I mean energy
the idea of energy I mean we have at
formulas for we got this and that we
have ways of transforming but the idea
of energy is a metaphor three is a
motive or three three sheep three cattle
three sticks that's fine so one of the
difficulties in making a link between
the two worlds I've got one foot in each
is to recognize this nature of human
language and I don't think artificial
intelligence is going to get too far and
in fact until we get something that can
understand more of the world we're not
going to get even I'm not going to get
anywhere what Eliza does and what most
of these other things are going to do is
just fake it or have a very restricted
domain one reason i picked counterpoint
as an example species counterpoint
probably no one has ever taken to
counterpoint class here start out with
first species you got whole notes
against whole notes and then you go to
second species half notes against whole
notes and you got rules and it got all
this stuff here and essentially everyone
since mozart learned how to write
counter pummel music in this way I mean
Bach have the thing but you already do
how do this stuff and one of the
challenges we've got it was going to be
it's pretty easy for first species
because you have very tight constraints
on what you can do
and the model the computer has to work
on is can be very simple but as you add
complexity with the further species
you're going to get to a point where
chatbots not going to be able to help
and I already know that fifth species is
out of the question won't work because
it's just too many things that can go
one and there's a line where you're
crossing between doing a simply
mechanical exercise and then doing
something that requires some thought
some aesthetic sense and the computer
has none so that's where I'm at I'm
going to continue working on this but
it'll be a backburner project because
the new audio stuff is really nice and
I'm going to be working on that so any
questions sure
[Applause]